more than 200 000 people in the united
states have now died after contracting
the coronavirus
it is the highest number for any country
in the world even though the u.s
accounts for only about four percent of
the global population
in the capital washington the u.s house
of representatives held a moment of
silence for the victims
led by speaker nancy pelosi
rise for a moment of silence and
remembrance of those
more than 200 000 americans who have
passed away from the coba 19
virus pelosi has blamed the deaths on
the disinformation
and negligence in tackling the pandemic
by the white house
but president donald trump insists that
the u.s is rounding the corner in the
pandemic
a claim that he has been making for
months the high death toll is putting
his handling of the coronavirus outbreak
in the spotlight as he campaigns
for a second term in office
we asked u.s citizens in the city of
denver what they had to say
about this tragic milestone i mean i
don't understand how the richest country
in the world
could have such a an extensive public
health crisis
i feel like if we had real leadership
that
the number would be much smaller we
think trump has done a good job
i i think that there's a a story on the
other side that wants to say how bad
he's handled it but
nobody knew where nobody knew where it
was coming from in the beginning or what
it was all about
and dw correspondent stephan simon sets
us this update from washington on
whether the country is likely to change
its course in dealing with the pandemic
well the president didn't promise
anything now today or yesterday or last
week or the week before that
the president is busy campaigning saying
that he did
everything possible and more than
than that to curb the uh threat
and the uh voracious outcome of this
kovat19 pandemic or kovite 19
infections here in the united states so
on part of the president
everything is done very very well and he
saved
the lives of millions in his mind
democrats are
furious about how the president handled
this kovit 19 crisis here
and say 200 000 deaths
in in just doubling the number this
number just doubling in two or three
months
uh is a clear sign that the president
mishandled
uh this crisis this pandemic uh in in a
very very very very large and
significant way
i can't foresee any scenario that the
united states
at this moment will unify after those
numbers after today after this
milestone passing 200 000 deaths to
combat this
coronavirus pandemic in any other way
and that was stefan simons in washington
amid the criticism of his handling of
the pandemic president trump has lashed
out at china
blaming it for spreading the virus trump
went on the attack
in a pre-recorded message to the u.n
general assembly
as the world body marks 75 years since
its founding
the annual gathering took place with
coronavirus restrictions in place
the perfect riverside spot for a
fractious global family get together at
un headquarters
face masks and tight security even
though the most distinguished guests
joined by videolink a precaution to
avoid worsening the coronavirus pandemic
that has already killed almost one
million people worldwide
two a half empty hall of socially
distanced un
ambassadors un chief antonio guterres
warned about tensions between the u.s
and china
threatening to tear the organization and
the world
apart let us vanquish the five horsemen
our world cannot afford the future where
the two largest economies split the
globe in a great fracture
each with its own trade and financial
rules and internet and artificial
intelligence capacities
technological and economic divide risks
inevitably turning into a geostrategic
and military divide and we must avoid
these
at all costs and the increasingly
difficult relationship between the two
superpowers was on show as soon as
president trump's pre-recorded statement
started rolling
honor to address the united nations
general assembly
75. the u.s leader said the u.n should
hold beijing accountable for the covert
19
crisis and trump
championed his policy of putting his
country's national
interests
for first the same tired voices proposed
the same failed solutions
pursuing global ambitions at the expense
of their own people
as president i have rejected the failed
approaches of the past
and i am proudly putting america first
just as
you should be putting your countries
first
with early voting for the u.s
presidential elections already underway
in some u.s states
trump's speech attacking china on trade
and the environment
was aimed as much at u.s voters as other
world
leaders in contrast the pre-recorded
speeches from russia's president putin
and chinese president xi jinping urged a
global response to the coronavirus
pandemic
and more cooperation between countries
we should embrace the vision of a
community with a shared future
we should see each other as members of
the same big family
pursue win-win cooperation and not fall
into the trap of a clash of
civilizations
this year's general assembly debate
underscores how hard it is to keep
countries talking to
each other instead of past each other
we've heard so many times that the best
diplomacy is done
in person this year thanks to the
pandemic we're not getting that we're
getting diplomacy
i guess on zoom does that make a
difference
i i think it really does i think it
really is a real problem brent i mean
of course it's normal for these speeches
by the leaders
uh in the general debate to be used as
grandstanding opportunities we've
certainly seen plenty of that today
we're going to talk about that i'm sure
in a moment but still
like the event every year in new york
is unique in the diplomatic calendar
it's the only time when all of these
leaders get an opportunity to come
together and it's what happens
outside that chamber outside those
speeches that that really matters when
there are opportunities for the leaders
and also their teams to talk to each
other
and to have kind of serendipitous
encounters which you know can be
fruitful so it is a real concern
particularly for believers in diplomacy
believers in this the power of
multilateralism and we heard today
on beginning with president trump he
opened the assembly on the day that
america surpassed the 2000 mark
the death toll from the pandemic two
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
yeah and i mean that's the the highest
level in the world and of course
characteristically for donald trump
uh when he's open for criticism he goes
on the attack
and uh that's what he did very robustly
within virtually his first breath he was
talking about the china virus
now there are genuine concerns about
china in the early stages of the
outbreak in wuhan in the center of the
country at the end of last year
beginning of this about
how transparent they were with the world
health organization
also with with other countries about
that
um but still this was pretty aggressive
even by donald trump's standards
um and also it's only adding to these
fears that the us and china just headed
for a kind of cold war
scenario which the u.n secretary general
guterres
explicitly warned against in his speech
who was donald trump speaking to today i
want you to take
a look at what the group america first
policies posted immediately after donald
trump's speech
take a look as we speak the united
states is also working to end the war in
afghanistan
and we are bringing our troops home
america is fulfilling our destiny as
peacemaker
but it is peace through strength
so richard what do we have there
re-election campaign spot
i mean it it's not that much of a
surprise when we were watching it
live earlier it was a very content
kind of hit list of donald trump's view
of the world and what he sees as his
achievements you know donald trump's is
usually long
famously rambling this was wham bam bam
so it's not much of a surprise but i
mean bear in mind there is an election
in just a few weeks i think any
president who was
heading into an election like this would
use an event like this
to some extent uh to try and make some
political points but of course this was
in
trump's style let's talk a little bit
about global geopolitics and how
it's reflected at this meeting this is
what the russian president vladimir
putin said
today about the status quo if you will
take a look
russia has suggested convening a g5
summit
it would aim at reaffirming the key
principles of behaviour in international
affairs
elaborating ways to effectively address
today's most burning issues
it is encouraging that our partners have
supported the initiative
a g5 summit for the five members of the
security council what does that tell us
about the present day balance of powers
yeah well
well it's interesting because he's
standing up for a system that many say
is
is discredited that the u.n security
council is no longer functioning
that it is in a state of almost
permanent deadlock with
vladimir putin and xi jinping from china
on one side the united states on the
other side
and each of those having veto powers
which means that they can each block
each other's initiatives
and this has you know concrete
implications i mean look at the war in
syria that dragged on
uh the security council was unable to
get over those
veto hurdles to do anything meaningful
to end that conflict
and many smaller countries or a
particular grouping of smaller countries
of which germany is a member is saying
that we need to reform the u.n security
council that it needs to get bigger they
need to get rid of these vetoes
it needs to get more diverse but the
thing is and what we see from putin here
of course the vested interests and the
powers of those members of the u.n
security council are just so
powerful and no one likes to give up
their powers no exactly no one wants to
change
the status quo when it means they would
lose power and yet you've got
donald trump champion an american
retreat from multilateralism
we're seeing that at the same time
you've got the chinese president xi
jinping
showing the world that china is here to
preserve
the global order as we know it well
that's his
argument and of course it's an easier
argument to make when you have donald
trump there
essentially saying that um well he said
that
every country should stand up for itself
making the nationalist argument
of course china's critics would say well
you know
xi jinping at the same time is involved
in a border confrontation with india
it's cracking down on human rights in
hong kong it threatens
taiwan with invasion and it is trying to
expand its
its control within the south china sea
that these are not the acts
of a benign multilateralist power and
as we go to air richard i mean if you
look on the home page of the new york
times
or the washington post for that matter
you will really have to struggle to find
an article about
these speeches and the u.n general
assembly today what does it tell us does
the u.n does it still matter well i
noticed the same thing and it is
striking that
german news sites are featuring donald
trump's speech more prominently than
many
uh american ones um i think we do have
to
stress though that kind of american
neglect and disinterest in the united
nations is nothing that new
i mean you remember back in 1997 ted
turner the founder of cnn
donated a billion dollars to the united
nations
at a time when congress had stopped
paying its dues
george bush nominated as the ambassador
to the un
uh a man who had said the best thing you
could do to the un was
to knock off a bunch of stories from the
building so
it's not so new i think um what's more
important really is
is or the bigger challenge to the un
at the moment is that so many countries
with the us at the pinnacle are led by
uh leaders who question the very idea
of international cooperation yeah that's
right there's a lot lots of enemies
right now of
multilateralism and those enemies are in
power around the world
richard walker our chief international
editor richard thank you
you